republicans have seen the polling
and they are terrified
that running strongly against all
abortions
is going to crush them in november so we
have to understand now on the left the
republicans have seen the polling they
know the numbers in the aftermath of the
repeal of roe v wade by the supreme
court the overturning of roe v wade by
the supreme court uh we have seen a
dramatic shift in polling for these
november midterm elections and i've told
you that we're going to look at the
numbers tomorrow or thursday but
the odds that democrats keep the senate
are now roughly two to one
democrats still
expected to lose the house but by a
smaller margin than at any point during
this midterm election cycle and much of
it much of it is because of the anger
about roe v wade being overturned and
the fundamental right to an abortion in
most cases disappearing republicans are
aware of this and we are now seeing a
number of different republicans either
in interviews or on their websites
change or certainly restructure the way
that they talk about abortion some of
them removing altogether their
anti-choice stances from their
respective websites so last week i
brought you the story of this democrat
in michigan who won in a swing district
in a special election by focusing in on
abortion just straight up one and it's
abundantly clear that this is a big risk
for republicans we now have a clip from
this is from yesterday or maybe the day
before yet no this is from yesterday
this is john o i believe it's pronounced
od might be o'day this is the republican
senate candidate in colorado
he went on fox news
and he made it very clear
he supports women's right to choose an
abortion early in the pregnancy and even
later when there are particular
circumstances take a listen to this a
very different sounding republican
martha thanks for having me on today i
really appreciate it you know your race
was very interesting one to watch you
beat a candidate who was more of a trump
supporter you are sort of running in a
more moderate lane and yet uh your
opponent the current senator michael
bennett is is looking to sort of peg you
that way a little bit more here's an
example in an ad that dropped on friday
watch this dropped
it makes the race for senate even more
important michael bennett has always
fought to protect a woman's right to
make her own health care decisions but
joe o'day opposes the law protecting
abortion access in colorado so we want
to give you a chance to respond to that
because clearly the roe v wade decision
is becoming a factor in races all across
the country we're going to see a lot of
ads like that are they accurately
portraying your view on this sir
that that adds dishonest it's at best um
i came out early on in this election and
said that i supported a woman's rights
early on in the pregnancy and even later
on to you know with mitigating
circumstances so i've been very vocal
about that issue ran my primary on that
and we ended up winning um you know so
this is very interesting because
i can't tell you
that if joe o'day
makes it uh
makes it to the senate
that he would actually be a pro-choice
vote i can't say that all week all we
can look at is what he's saying today
and he has made i believe the correct
calculation that at this point
when it comes to democrats
and even moderate republicans
it is not a good idea to take these
wacky anti-choice views in a state like
colorado when you're running in the
senate now if you are running in a
particular
red district
for the house
in alabama it's a very different story
but he's correctly sort of taking the
pulse of the electorate in colorado and
the pulse of the country and if he is
going to defeat bennett and tr and get
to the senate
with that electorate and the entire
state of colorado as the voting
constituency he can't be a wacky
anti-choicer now he may be an
anti-choicer personally but he has made
the correct calculation that he can't
really be running that way this is not
super unique we're seeing instances of
this elsewhere as well in arizona four
days ago
blake masters right wing nut
backtracks on abortion and scrubs his
campaign website this is all from the
last week so blake masters realizing i
might want to ease up on some of the
anti-abortion stuff
um
another example here
republican congressional candidate and
state senator tom barrett
totally removed the value section of his
campaign website which touted his
anti-abortion position and history with
the pro-life movement also making the
calculation that listen even if these
are my views
and even if this is how i'm ultimately
going to vote if the people elect me i
don't necessarily want to be promoting
this and making it front and center this
is a very important shift now what are
what are the going to be the substantive
repercussions of such a shift we we
actually don't know yet because part of
it is
are these republicans actually becoming
mildly pro-choice or are they just lying
because they see that that's what they
need to do in order to get themselves
elected and it won't actually change
anything if and when they do
that's a it's a predictive question
we're just guessing we don't have the
answer but the fact that they're feeling
the need to change their messaging on
this issue is already extraordinarily
important let me know what you make of
this are these candidates
is there going to be a wave of
pro-choice republicans or are these
merely the lies they're willing to tell
in order to get themselves elected
because they've sort of put their finger
to the wind and feel the way that it's
blowing let me know tomorrow night 6 pm
eastern it is finally here i know many
of you have been waiting for so long it
is the david pakman show members only
town hall we will open up the phone
lines exclusively to our members
tomorrow at 6 pm eastern every member is
welcome to participate and chat with me
it will be streaming live on youtube
twitch and facebook so everybody is free
to watch but we will just be inviting
our members to participate in the town
hall still time to sign up at join
joinpackman.com